this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks mark thanks everybody for coming
today it's always fun to come back and
see familiar faces I want to start by
reminding us all that plant breeding is
actually a very dynamic science so over
the years we constantly innovate and and
develop new methods technologies and
tools to try to accelerate gain from
selection for example in 1950s and 60s
we saw the development of selection
indices and Bluff in the 70s 80s and 90s
among many other things we saw a market
selection double haploids and then from
2000 on today the era that we're
currently in of course we see genomic
selection high-throughput phenotyping
among other things and we're constantly
trying to develop and strive for ways to
get faster rates of genetic game you
know the difficulty with all of this is
that we develop these tools and methods
there's generally a very large gap
between what we know how to do and the
technologies we have available and what
actually gets used in breeding programs
around the world for example I mentioned
Bluff best linear unbiased prediction
it's was developed in the 50s and 60s
and still today they're they're not
every breeding program is using it so we
still we just have this very big gap and
if I look reflect back on a lot of my
work up until now it's really been on
trying to kind of close this gap between
what we can do what technologies are
available and what get used in breeding
programs to try to accelerate rates of
genetic gain and under that category I'm
going to talk about some of my gentlemen
selection research they did well at
CIMMYT while working with CIMMYT and on
work I did at Erie which was on
measuring rates of genetic gain for
potentially to be used for monitoring
and evaluation of breeding programs and
then lastly I'll talk just a little bit
about some current and future research
on small greens breeding at the
University of Illinois sort where I am
currently at so I want to start
before I get into the talk at all I want
to go back and rewind and say why I got
into my breeding I spent even
agriculture in the first place and its
really because when I was 18 years old I
left the country for the first time I
started traveling around South America I
went to Bolivia for the first time out
of the country and I did a lot of
traveling with friends I met through
study abroad probably spent around a
year in total traveling between Bolivia
and Argentina and then it was during
that time probably spent a lot of hours
on bus trips long bus trips thinking
about what to do with my life and
somehow I decided that I want to do
something good for the world and that
agriculture was something was some was
it was what I should do and then when I
heard about the International
Agricultural Research Center as part of
the CGIAR of course I was naturally
attracted to that and and their mission
to develop these breeding materials as
international public goods for use all
around the world to improve agriculture
and in many parts of the world and then
after my PhD here had this wonderful
opportunity to work between Cornell and
CIMMYT and to try to get a lot of the
knowledge and the ideas learned here
during you know research being done here
and translate that into an applied
reading program with the CIMMYT wheat
program and at CIMMYT there's this core
to its breeding breeding strategy is the
shuttle breeding approach which breeding
materials go between central and north
mexico and then between Mexico and Kenya
to impose selection for different traits
you know adaptation also resistance to
various diseases
and this shuttle breeding strategy is
very much core to this program's
strategy and and the way the way that it
does things and and I should also
mention it's not just the reading
materials that are shuttling between the
different sites it's also the scientists
and and the breeders going and following
their populations and selecting within
them and among them and so a lot of time
and resources are so for example I
participated in just you know some parts
of this and so august-september was
single spike selection in central Mexico
November December I came back here in
seven week course then March April May
was single psych spike selection in
northern Mexico and then in Kenya you
can see a lot of time and resources are
devoted to this this approach and there
has been quite a lot of success in
developing especially disease resistant
lines in this kind of approach and all
this emphasis placed on spending time in
the field at the plants no visual
selection it all stems back to Norman
Borlaug who was the original founder of
this of the symmetry breeding program
and he's always quoted for saying to
this day he's quoted for saying this
week we'll talk to you if you listen the
third the second part I didn't know
people don't normally say this part but
the full quote is this week will talk to
you if you listen but you can't hear it
if you sit under a tree and watch other
people doing the work and that
definitely is the philosophy and it's
the work culture and you know it's
images you have to spend time with the
plants in the field doing the selection
and that's that's very much core to the
heart of the the breeding program of
course we all you know what I learned in
grad school and what many of us learn
visual selection is can its although
it's somewhat effective it's a
relatively inefficient selection method
and if you of course if you devote a lot
of time and energy and resources you can
get some gain out of it but it may not
be the most efficient way of doing
things here
but some some images of this of the
visual selection process here on the
you'll see selection within wheat
populations in in Kenya and then
breeders selecting among grain looking
by looking at grain characteristics
among lines in Mexico so it's quite a
bit so quite a lot of emphasis on on
visual selection and I thought there
must be a way to improve upon this
approach at least you know maybe replace
some instances of visual selection with
a more data-driven or prediction model
based selection to improve that
efficiency and I thought one way is that
certainly should work would be to use
both high-throughput phenotyping and
genomic prediction together to help
improve selection accuracy for grain
yield and this seemed kind of easy at
the time because we had already had the
marker data being generated and all the
high-throughput phenotypic data was
already also being generated and this is
the kind of approach I took I used data
from high-throughput phenotypic data
from traits we typically measure in
high-throughput phenotyping like canopy
temperature measured both in vegetative
and grain filling stage and then two
different NDVI indices measured both in
grain filling and vegetated stages and
then on the training set I assume all
these I use all the data on these traits
in addition to grain yields and then on
the test set the individuals were trying
to predict I'm using all the data from
high-throughput phenotyping but assume
that yield is not observed and this
might be useful in a case where you have
many many plots that actually don't get
harvested there are some there are some
cases where this is this is happening in
the breeding program many many plots
that don't get harvested and they might
be visually selecting okay I took a
pretty simple approach to this problem
and I used a multi trait Bluff model
where we have the
observe ations or genetic values from a
you know second stage of analysis her
traits as our response variable we have
fixed effects that can be different for
trait and then random effects of the
genotypes also on each trait and the key
factor here that allows us to predict is
that we have the genetical variances
between the individuals as well as among
traits that allows us sharing of
information between correlated traits as
well as relatives and not surprisingly
we found that using secondary traits in
this multi trait block approach
increases the prediction accuracy
compared to just a univariate blob or
something we typically do to predict all
the time just using BLUP you know
genomic selection so the ordinary
univariate model is shown accuracies are
shown in yellow here for three different
environments optimal severe drought and
late heat these are simulated
environments all in on the same
Experiment Station and within a panel
I'm showing if we use the genomic
relationship matrix or if we use the
pedigree relationship matrix the red and
the blue are showing with the accuracies
with the multivariate model with in the
red is showing with unreplicated data
which is a more realistic scenario and
with the blue with the replicated data
and we always see that the multivariate
blob we increase accuracy and this is
pretty much expected because we're
observing all this phenotypic data on
our our candidates well one thing it's
kind of interesting at least was to me
was that there is hardly any difference
between genomic and pedigree based
predictions and normally you know we
know that with a pedigree we can't
select within families but if we start
using phenotypic data
we can actually select within families
because we're capturing some of that
Mendelian sampling term so that even
opens up more options for how you might
use this approach even if you didn't
have market data you could still use
multi trail up with your secondary
traits and get a good selection accuracy
so it just opens up the options you know
even more even if you didn't have the
resources for genotyping had a certain
breeding stage now there's at CIMMYT
this is not to brag or anything but we
did a lot of other validation cross
validation studies and looking at
genomic selection high-throughput
phenotyping or the combination of the
two these are just some of the articles
that you know I participated in in some
way but there are many others even
before I came and after I left but we
never could seem to get past this phase
of just cross validation and proof of
concept and just kind of looking at
existing data sets we could never really
move it forward I think there there was
just a lot of hesitation towards the
technology itself and not you know not a
huge not not a lot of you know not a lot
of embracing of the the ideas and so
then when I saw this opportunity to come
at Erie part of the reason why I went to
to work at Erie was because not as much
work had been done in this area compared
to at CIMMYT and I thought I could
probably make a bigger contribution
there by you know starting and doing
more of the initial legwork on genomic
selection and high-throughput
phenotyping and then right around the
same time I got to Erie there's a lot of
these initiatives to try to drive
breeding technology adoption and this
was a lot spurred by Gates Foundation's
especially Gary Atlin was the champion
of this and he he's quoted for saying
you know management culture and metrics
need to change so he's more in favor of
let's just tell people to do it and make
them do it sort of approach like a
top-down way of doing things and and in
and he really strongly believes that the
rate of genetic gain and armour and
researcher
managed trials is the key to measuring
breeding program effectiveness and so
this has been his big push he wants to
to use metrics use rate of genetic gain
potentially as a way to monitor and
evaluate breeding programs to help
incentivize or you know between use
carrots and sticks to help from a
breeding program with adoption now the
difficulty with looking at rates of
genetic gain and routinely estimating
them is that the phenotypic trends that
we can easily observe in our data it's a
product of both genetic trends and
non-genetic trends here's just some crop
production trends across the United
States for different crops and this is a
phenotypic trend there's we don't know
how much of this is due to genetics
because there's also agronomic trends
agronomists are developing new
technologies and ways of growing crops
climates changing and so on so there's
really no way to separate this just by
looking at this data and I came to
appreciate this a lot more after working
with this long term experiment which is
which is grown at Erie this is the long
term continuous cropping experiment it's
been grown since 1960s and there's three
different seasons it's continuous rice
and it's always flooded there's never a
break there's not there's no crop
rotation so there's three seasons dry
season early wet season late wet season
there's treatment with no fertilizer
there's treatment with fertilizer high
fertilizer and there's also two phases
of the experiment which correspond to
the leadership of that experiment and
the management practices used and what
we see in this from looking at this data
in separating agronomic and genetic
trends is that there's a pretty
consistent downward trend of you know
decreasing yields over time for example
it's around 42 kilograms per hectare per
year and
it's plus or minus depending on the what
season it is and what nitrogen treatment
and that's pretty consistent and so if
we were to just look at and and just
ignore this kind of a trend in our in
our data we might actually not see any
phenotypic progress at all it might look
completely flat because our Nega
agronomic trend our environmental trend
may be cancelling out our genetic game
trend so it's important to keep in mind
that these these non genetic trends are
happening now in selection experiments a
way to try to get a sense of the rate of
genetic gain and to try to get rid of
order to count for these other types of
trends or is this to you as a control
population and here's an example from a
selection experiment in mice for nesting
behavior you can see that the top line
is the selection for more greater
nesting behavior the bottom is less
nesting behavior in the middle is the
control population that's with no
selection so that's only capturing
differences in the environment or any
kind of non genetic trend that there may
be and by looking at the trend in the
control you can easily or the the
deviate the fluctuations in the control
we can understand what how much is due
to genetic and how much is environmental
or other factors now animal breeders
they wanted they've always wanted to
look at their rates of genetic gain
genetic trends over time but it would be
extremely expensive to try to have a
control population of something like
cattle you know just to be just to
measure genetic trends what animal
breeders have done is use blob and
estimate breeding values and look at
trends in those breeding values over
time and there's some work done many
years ago show that this can be
effective as long as the estimates of
variance our variance components are
accurate and more recently in
crop datasets there was some work done
by people at all looking at dissecting
non-genetic and genetics trends in
German variety trials and this takes a
similar approach in that he uses a mixed
model with all the data and tries to
estimate both agronomic and genetic
trends using a mixed model approach and
the basic idea in any of these methods
where we're trying to look at rates of
genetic gain is that we need to know
what's the average to genetic or
breeding value for individuals born are
generated in a given year and how does
that average change over time and that
slope of that trend is should be the
rate of genetic game if you want to try
to estimate this from our data sets
using the animal breeding approach or
the variety trial approach we need to
have pretty good connectivity in the
data set here I'm showing an example of
a disconnected data set where we have
genotypes that they don't overlap
between between the years and that's
what we don't want that's disconnected
and then on the on the right I'm showing
you a connected data set where we have
some overlap between individuals
genotypes in the years but the question
is like how much overlap do you need
it's kind of subjective you know you
don't know if it's gonna be enough just
by eyeballing the data set you can guess
only here's just some connectivity of in
a real rice testing Network data so this
is from my real experience where people
came to me and said well I need to
estimate rates of genetic game here this
is my data set and so I look at it and
say you know okay
is there enough connectivity here here
so I'm just showing in this matrix the
lines number of lines that overlap
between the years different years and
it's about you know consecutive years
might overlap by three to ten
individuals but for for the most part
most of the lines are only tested one
year for example 750 of the lines were
tested one year there
3:36 lines tested for two years and 32
tested for three so there isn't a whole
lot of connectivity there but it's hard
to say if it's enough or not now looking
at this data set and s using different
methods to estimate rates of genetic
game ended up getting extremely
different results in one case and one
method I got negative 17 kilograms per
hectare per year and in one method I got
positive 43 and you know I guess you
could pick whichever one you want you
know whatever argument you're trying to
make you could pick but that's probably
not the right thing to do so in order to
try to get to the bottom of this and to
try to figure out what would be the best
or most appropriate method if you're
gonna try to try to use breeding data
breeding program data to estimate recent
genetic game and the only you know way I
thought I could do this was using
simulation because in order to test if
these methods are working I have to know
what's the true rate of genetic game and
the only way is through simulation so I
simulated breeding programs a eight
different breeding scenarios you know
two different testing schemes two
different levels of heritability a
positive non genetic trended a negative
non-genetic trend and I tried to make it
relatively realistic to something we
might observe in rice breeding and but
it also applies to other salt pollinated
crops the breeding schemes are quite
similar here are the results of the nut
of the true genetic trends for all the
eight different breeding scenarios so I
can show you here there's have one panel
that's high heritability positive non
genetic trend with testing scheme a and
so on and each each scenario was
repeated ten times so I had a total of
80 different breeding programs
simulated
I used I tried all these different
methods one is the familiar era trial
method which which we all know and I
think is the most widely used in plant
breeding where we take varieties the
best material from the different years
and just test them all in one year and
then estimate a trend I tried the
estimated breeding value method this
variety trial methods that was proposed
by people at all 2014 and then a control
population method which uses a long term
checks as the to serve as a control
population and then phenotype which is a
naive method where I don't attempt at
all to remove non-genetic trends just
look at the trend in the phenotype and
what I found was the control population
and the EBV methods they did it work the
best if you look at just the past 15
years of data which was more realistic
to what you might actually find in a
breeding program it's pretty clear EBV
control population are the two best
methods they're not significantly
different and here I'm just looking
showing you the error so this is the
different absolute difference between
the true rate of gain and the rate that
is estimated then the next best would be
the era trial method in in that 15 years
scenario if you look at a lot more years
of data so twenty-eight year all 28
years of the breeding program that I
simulated the era the error starts it
decreases in some cases and the control
population method it decreases so that
method becomes more accurate and then we
see that the EBV and the variety trial
and error trial methods they all are
performing similarly the main message is
you know having a lot of years really
makes a big difference I tried even less
years than 15 I didn't even I didn't
show it in the paper but I could not get
any good results with anything less than
15 years found that long term checks
definitely reduce the error especially
in the variety trial method all the
results I showed you on the previous
slide assume that there is five checks
tested across all the years so not
having those checks it does increase the
error a little bit if you're using the
EBV method and it increases there a lot
if you're using the variety trial method
then so that variety trial method is
very sensitive the connectivity in the
data whereas EBV is maybe a little bit
less sensitive probably because we're
using you're getting connectivity and
from using the relationship matrix now
one thing that was kind of surprising to
me that I found was there's systematic
errors in estimates of rate of genetic
gain that means that the error that you
find in your estimate is associated with
the breeding scheme or the breeding
scenario that you have so for example if
you just look at this panel we're
looking at the EBV method take a look at
this box here this is with a negative
non-genetic trend testing scheme a and
low heritability so that's that's like
one breeding program scenario that has a
very positive error so that that rate of
genetic gain is always getting
overestimated by quite a lot in that
scenario then if you have let's say of
this scenario this is positive non
genetic trend testing scheme a and high
heritability that all those breeding
programs with those scenarios with that
scenario they're always getting under
their rate of get gain is always getting
underestimated and
what that means is it makes it really
difficult to compare among breeding
programs like if if this is my breeding
program and that's your breeding program
we could be achieving the exact same
level of game but I'm doing like I'm
looking way better than you so it's kind
of a problem because kind of I feel like
kind of the whole point of doing this is
to sort of compare so if that's I think
that that we probably have to keep that
in mind if we're gonna be doing this
it's sort of like fYI let's keep it
track of the population but not as I'm
better than you sort of thing so we
probably should be careful with that the
other thing that I discovered as I was
doing this work and at talking to people
and they come to me with their data and
say I want to estimate Janak it's a
genetic gain I realized that not all
breeding efforts are designed to achieve
genetic game just think of back crossing
you know back crossing doesn't achieve
game it just shoots something else it
has a different goal and another big
example is like it could type based
breeding so it was idiot eye preening
you're trying to achieve you know an
ideal genotype that's also not a
population improvement approach it's
maybe a gene pyramiding approach or in
it for example this this idiot I based
reading has been proposed in many crops
I'm just showing one example in rice
because it was an Erie and this started
a lot in 1989 there was this push
towards like a new plant type and all
these parents these are all land races
that were donors of the different traits
that would be needed to achieve that
true plant type a new plant type it's a
totally different approach kind of a
different theoretical framework than
what we think about when we're in a
quantitative genetics and population
improvement I'm not trying to say that
there's zero merit in India type reading
maybe there is Green Revolution was in
fact based on an idiot type but it is
not the purpose of video type reading is
not population improvement therefore
if you have this kind of a breeding
strategy it wouldn't make sense to try
to measure rates of genetic game and
that made me think you know it should be
really easy to develop kind of a litmus
tests or just to diagnose you know is
this a population improvement program is
this something is there is this breeding
program going using a strategy which is
consistent with achieving gain from
selection over time and I stumbled a
crowd across this metric which is the
equivalent complete generation which
looks at the pedigree depths big
assumption here is that you have
accurate pedigrees and what this
basically indicates is the cycle of
breeding that has been completed how
many how many breeding cycles without
breeding cycles by definition you can't
get genetic gain and here from this is
from simulations look this is the
average equivalent compute generations
over time and the mean true breeding
value over time you can see they're
pretty closely associated with one
another you need to have breeding cycles
to achieve genetic game and it's
something you know we can really easily
use just to look and see how the
breeding programs have been structured
potentially and here I'm showing you
this is looking at the the variety
trends also from the varieties that were
planted in the in the long term
experiment that I talked about before
here I have I'm showing the equivalent
complete generations which is the
indication of the breeding cycle and in
the first phase of the experiment is
mostly positive in the second phase it
appears somewhat negative and then the
yield breeding value is also small
somewhat of a similar trend in the first
phase it's slightly increasing and then
in the second phase it's mostly not
changing so it seems that this kind of a
is kind of an indicator might be useful
so I think some of
messages as I learned throughout this
process first we should maybe ask is
Janet again expected is this something
we should be doing and then we need to
if you want to get a good estimate it's
gonna take a lot of years of data to get
if you really want to try to get
something accurate and then choose a
method compatible with your data and
it's not necessarily going to be the
same method for everyone it just depends
what data is there in many cases you
might have to do an era trial there
maybe there isn't historical data
available for this and then the third or
the fourth point is just to be wary of
genetic gain estimates because they can
be biased and we probably you know
shouldn't be using them to make really
momentous decisions and then the
question is then if we can't you know
really convince people by doing a bunch
of research to adopt a breeding
technology and you can't use carrots and
sticks via rates of genetic gain so what
do you do what's left how do we promote
the best use of breeding technologies
and I think I started to realize I kind
of agree with what Max Planck said in
1950 because a new scientific truth does
not triumph by convincing its opponents
and making them see the light but rather
because a new generation grows up that
is familiar with it so it's all about
the next generation of people that all
we know is blump really we don't know
any other way and so that brings me to
the University of Illinois and my new of
my new position as assistant professor
of small grains breeding as I took over
this breeding program that has been
going on for many years under the
direction of Fred Kolb who just retired
and so I'm building on early strong
legacy and moving it forward and just
gonna talk very briefly about some of
the things I'm doing in the breeding
program because I now I get to be that
next generation
so we have our target population
environments is pretty small it's
basically the state of Illinois there's
some spill over into neighboring states
of course but we focus on Illinois
there's we have for testing main testing
locations where our breeding large
number of breeding materials is tested
and and they are primarily in the in the
major wheat growing region of Illinois
which is in the South now in southern
Illinois we have very common cropping
system which is double cropping wheat
with soybeans so the soybean is planted
in October harvested in June and then
the soybeans planted in June and that
system allows week to remain profitable
in the state otherwise many cases it's
just difficult to break even growing
wheat some really important quality
traits also you know that are very
important to profitability of course is
is Don dioxane eval and all caused by
bazarian head blight test weight which
is these two things affect the price of
the grain that the farmer receives so
they're very important and of course we
we always make sure that varieties
released have good milling and baking
quality because the milling and baking
industry you know really relies on - I'm
having these quality good quality and
something which I've always wanted to do
and I finally get to do it is I can
select for a net merit using economic
weights and the main traits that affect
the profitability of wheat in Illinois
it's primarily Don tests wait days to
maturity and yield with Don of course
there's these discount rates applied at
the elevator where the farmer sells the
grain so we know exactly you know what
the association between the level of Don
and the price of the wheat the same is
true for test weight we know how you
know different levels of tests weight
and what price of the grain you will get
days to maturity we know is associated
with profitability because the sooner
the farmer can harvest the wheat the
sooner they plant the soybean and the
higher yield they get on the soybean so
we know it's about
half a bushel or acre increase in yield
for each day earlier that the week can
be harvested so we know that
relationship and of course we know the
relationship was yield because we know
what the price of the grain is so those
are the main traits that's going into a
basically plug that in and I calculate
net merit for every cross and for every
line and I based primarily the selection
is based on that but I do consider a lot
about all these other traits so I have
variety selection trace these are all
the traits that maybe are in a seed
catalog but the farmer looks at and
maybe considers when in selecting a
variety and then secondary what I call
secondary population improvement traits
these are all related we measure these
these are related to our are traits of
economic value and they are helpful in
just in direct selection or in
prediction the breeding scheme is pretty
it's pretty straightforward we have at
least a bit at the very minimum 200
crosses a year we select single spikes
in the f3 of 20,000 f4 head rows and
then enter into at least three stages of
yield testing the first stages in two
locations and the remaining testing is
in four locations and for the most part
I haven't made to the basic structure of
the program I haven't made changes at
least not yet but I'm adding sort of
these extra layers and new ways of doing
things
partially replicated designs and more
randomization multi trade genomic
selection and then an area which I
really wanted to get into haven't
started yet it's high throughput
phenotyping for disease resistance and
phenology because phenology is very
important in our region for the crosses
and we're predicting where we're doing
parent and cross selection based on net
merit and coming soon we doing optimum
contribution selection to avoid
inbreeding and this is very much to be
continued around time to get into all
the details but please contact me at my
email address here if you would like
more to learn more also we're hiring
so don't hesitate to send me an email
and I acknowledge so there's so many
people I have to acknowledge I just
acknowledge a very few people here on
this side and donors and that I can take
questions over time especially old
varieties they've gone through a lot of
CDs not really skilled selection on hey
they're just there every five years or
ten years it being increased and so they
should be building up cultures to
patients without a purge so anything not
about we test eight year old yeah I do
they may have gone for eight or sixteen
rounds of increase and that's a lot of
load yeah I thought of that you know so
the question is about whether just you
know through maintaining the seed we're
accumulating deleterious mutations right
yeah I thought about this cuz I you
always see trends if you look at the
same variety grown across time you'll
often see these strong word trends and
it could be loss of disease resistance
it could be Delta deleterious mutations
I thought about this probably the most
likely answer is the disease resistance
lost but any mutations I think could be
contributing yeah yeah so I wouldn't
extrapolate this to the whole like
greeting because this is just a few
varieties selected for this experiment
but yeah it's a good
and I think partially what was happening
could have been happening is crossing
with older materials like to try to
bring in more traits like diseases or
some of these plant type traits that we
do see that I mean obviously the
pedigree depth goes down so that means
that we're crossing with older materials
who could be crossing across mabeland
races a lot of crosses were made with
ir8 actually relatively recently so I
think that has a contribution yeah I
think it's just the structure of the
data itself oh yeah so this is the bias
from this sort of bias that comes from
that we see in the estimates of rate of
genetic game I think it's just the
structure of the data itself and also I
mean I couldn't really make very clear
sense of it honestly I got like it was
like sometimes the negative genetic the
ones with negative genetic trend were
getting overestimated which was opposite
of what I would think so I couldn't
really make sense of why this is
happening it's some artifacts in the
data as we really release only a handful
of products except population form as
opposed to just well I think like it's
not very sustainable if we just try to
maximise finding the one variety like
you can do that it's short-term but then
you're gonna have to keep testing more
and more and more and more material and
there it's I think if you just think
about the best way to use your resources
you're gonna be more efficient with
resources if you do it incrementally
what is the view highly drives and
hybrid wheat
of the future question I don't know I
think Oh what's the future of hybrid
rice or hybrid wheat I don't know I
think wheat I'll I'll believe it when I
see it I guess I don't know that's why I
mean I have an open mind about it but I
don't know if it's coming anytime soon
yeah in in rice in the Philippines I
think but something like this I don't
remember the exact prices but the seed
was like maybe seven times at least more
expensive or it was it was like many
many many times more expensive than just
regular in breads and the yield
advantage is not to that same multiplier
so it's I think we have a ways to go so
I mean the question is like what's the
balance between like going out on the
field versus yeah actually definitely
like when I it's a lot more effective if
I analyze the data and look at the data
and what lies are performing best and
it's a lot more effective for me to do
that
and then when I go to the field it's
like I'm meeting a celebrity in person
and then I'm like okay I want to see you
know is this real is this a real thing
or are there other defects that I'm not
aware of I think that that's the you
know when talking about population
improvement I think that you can crunch
a lot of numbers and make progress if
you want to release a variety you still
have to look at it there might be things
that you never even expect it might
happen and you might see okay this might
be not a successful product it may be a
good parent but I'm not gonna maybe
release it as variety for because
whatever reason the farmer isn't gonna
like it so I think there's still a
little bit of both you know but but not
you know to the level of like I mean my
opinion is I don't feel like we need to
touch every last plant you know and with
our own hands and might be too much this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu